Russia has shelled nine Ukrainian
communities located in the northeastern
Sumi region of Ukraine artillery mortars
and tank grounds are being fired daily
in the area same bastravi joins us from
Sumi close to the Russian border Zane
what's been happening there
well we're here in the capital of the
Sumi region the region has one of the
longest continuous borders with Russia
but unlike some of the more contested
Ukrainian areas in the east
it isn't an active front line
necessarily you don't see tanks and
trenches and troop movements but scenes
like this are a near daily occurrence
across the region now we're here at the
site of a home that is now being
debris is being pulled out this was a
home that was destroyed by a Russian
strike about 10 days ago and what you
see here now is clearing work debris
being cleared from a house that was
a residence to a 71 year old man and a
65 year old woman they were trapped
under the debris both pulled out alive
but unfortunately the woman passed away
in a hospital now we've been speaking to
the owner of this house he said that in
the aftermath of the attack and the days
that followed Russian social media
characterized this as a military
production facility we asked him for his
reaction to that and he couldn't even
speak he said he found it so ridiculous
he didn't even know what to say his wife
died as a result of being trapped in
this Rubble you see the rubble is still
being cleared and the residents of this
area say there was nothing here but
civilian homes shrapnel can be seen as
it pierced houses all around this area
many people were injured and sites like
this in the Sunni region are very common
again no real heavy military targets
mostly civilian areas and we spoke to
the man who lost his wife whose home
this is and we asked him what he wanted
he people to know he said that people
here don't want to hurt Russians but
they do want Justice and they want the
war to be over as soon as possible
reporting from Sumi in eastern Ukraine
thank you